je les fais actuelle me voir ici
et
machenaud que t'as pas tellement changé
depuis deux ans je t'avais déjà
rencontrés ici tu as bien peu de choses
tu changerais crois en toi si tu avais
une baguette magique je me donnerai
peut-être la chevelure de robert redford
je voulais ressembler à qui quand
j'étais petit j'étais petit sans doute à
napoléon
tu crois que tu ferais quoi tu y dépasse
les terres général du rpr
l'embarras du choix j'ai envie de faire
plein de choses écrire par exemple quoi
tout et n'importe quoi tu crois que tu
seras président de la république un jour
toujours raison si tu étais une star du
rock ça serait qui peut-être un groupe à
moi tout seul
peut-être les rita mitsouko c'est avec
eux que j'ai inauguré la cigale en 18ème
arrondissement une chouette soirée site
était une star du cinéma
j'avais envie d'être burt lancaster dans
des langues et arts que tout change pour
ce tour de babel de ville et de la télé
toi kyle normale sup la grecque science
pour lennar ne crois pas que tu as été
un peu trop longtemps à l'école pour
diriger un mouvement qui veut retrouver
ses assises populaires agents viennent
du pasteur puis j'ai bossé on ne les a
pas donné tout ce diplôme puis je suis
élu d'un quartier populaire où je vois
des tas de gens on se trompe beaucoup
sur le métier des élus on n'est pas là
pour faire des discours là pour
rencontrer ceux qui nous font confiance
ça maintient un contact quels rapports
ou quelle différence y at il entre le
gaullisme et le chiraquisme à ce
programme de vol c'était l'histoire
chirac sélectivité
si de gaulle revenez demain matin qui
penserait coins de la france 2 88
peut-être qu'ils utiliseraient le même
mot qu'il avait utilisé à quelques
années la chienlit
mais je crois qu'il aurait conscience
parce que ya beaucoup de ressources dans
ce pays un homme politique c'est fait
pour imaginer l'avenir tu la vois
comment toi la france de l'an 2000 veut
plutôt pas mal parce que je trouve que
ces jeunes ont du tonus faut une
certaine manière mon admiration titteri
aujourd'hui on reparle de la bombe
atomique du sida du chômage malgré ça a
été le choc alors je crois qu'il a
aucune raison de se désespérer c'est
quel maître du monde
tu ferais quoi en premier la halle
secrétaire-général de rtl avec beaucoup
de choses à dire faire en sorte que les
jambes ce chapeau y pas beau des
questions subalternes poste un grand
rêve les corrections de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou